[Musique]
par les enfants beaux soient pas trop
jeter sans vite chez v2 petit ami ils
vont nous raconter une histoire du petit
chat oui vas-y vite de north vous savez
il est très amusant ce petit chat au
monde fr l
europe a tout de suite patron a tout de
suite de nos
eaux
bonsoir les enfants
as tu été sage aujourd'hui tu ressors
non on vagabonde
tué au cou une du petit chat
je vous écoute
de dos de lama chasse aux petits chats
et elle lui a donné trois côtes salengro
sur la neige trois coups sur les
oreilles nick
et sa toilette et fatale à elle s'est
couchée en raw s est endormi mais les
châteaux
sur le report de la fin lui non une
jeune chouette trop et blanche qu'il
regardait rêve de gros yeux ce que les
trop
[Musique]
le petit chien a sauté sur le rebord de
la fenêtre le garnement
les petits chats essayer d'attraper la
chouette net elle s'est envolée
mettons peu porteur et il ne s'est pas
fait mal et la chouette s'est mis à
voler autour du clocher de l'église
bien joué
le petit chat à monter toutes les
manches du clocher jusqu'au
bout quoi
le chaton ou à jus a sauté sur le toit
de l'église sur le clash et
l'or
est la chouette blanche s'était envolé
le pauvre petit chat à 20,3 peu le coq
du clocher il avait peur car le vent le
faisait tourner très vite mieux ou bien
ils criaient si fort qui leur revenaient
tout le choix du quartier mais pas
à ma peau elle est venue chercher il n'a
ramené à la maison elle lui a donné
trois coups de sabre sur les trois coups
sur les oreilles trois coups ce petit
manteau il pas de fessée elle a mis en
dodon
la petite chouette blanche avec toutes
les autres chouette rayée bien formant
la nuit
[Rires]
je me suis bien amusé
sacré petit chat est atteint avec ses
petites pattes
mais où sont-ils tempes rasées
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants
la jette à la lune heures
ados gants
un micro le nonce à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle était très jolie cette histoire
tient un chat meuh non pas trop c'est
moi nounours hop hop hop hop hop je veux
bien être plus louis allons en route
pour aux farceurs dos nu des enfants
car au fait que pour s
[Musique]
oh